in einem schweizer betreibungsamt sind
frühaufsteher am berg und jeden morgen
dasselbe ritual betreibungen von
gläubigern gehen ein
allein hier in lausanne 500 betreibungs
belehren täglich doppelt so viele wie
vor 25 jahren den stapel abzubauen
dauert eine dreiviertelstunde für die
betriebenen gehen hier die probleme erst
richtig los
sie haben eine pfändung der fluss wegen
ihre krankenkassenprämien in höhe von
1250 franken 30 können sie heute etwas
davon bezahlen
leider nein gut dann müssen wir schauen
ja geboren am 19 januar 1966 heimatort
nagoya
sie sind geschieden ja wachsen
circa 6.000 600 meter
ok haben sie ein auto nein ich benutze
immer öffentliche verkehrsmittel eine
lebensversicherung
es ist eine einfache rechnung
man lässt sie ein existenzminimum und
der rest des einkommens wird
beschlagnahmt
sind sie hausbesitzer als verfahren ganz
einfach es dauert so lange bis die
betreffenden schulden beglichen sind
wir machen es so ich brauche ihre
ausweise und wir schauen was gepfändet
werden kann
sie erhalten dann schriftlich bescheid
es geht mit zahlungsaufforderungen los
und plötzlich steckt man in der mühle
drin
man kann die schulden nicht mehr
bezahlen weil kein geld da ist und dann
kommen noch gebühren dazu für die
betreibung den rechtsweg und so weiter
ganz schnell kommt eins zum anderen
der berg wird immer größer und du
verlierst im überblick du steckst nicht
nur mit der nase drin ist ein schwarzes
loch und hast auch nichts mehr lust sagt
nur ich und du denkst
die einzige lösung wäre zu verschwinden
es ist bereits der ihf 50 53 1000
franken schulden fast acht prozent aller
schweizer haushalte haben mit ihren
schulden zu kämpfen
das sind 570.000 betroffen
das bundesamt für statistik spricht von
größeren kontoüberziehungen oder
kritischen zahlungsrückständen bisher
sprach man vorwiegend von klassischen
überschuldung fällen und leuten die sich
selbst hineinmanövriert hatten mehrere
kleinkredite kein umgang mit geld und
oft ein tiefes lohnniveau aber diese art
der überschuldung ist heute zumindest
teilweise überholt
wie würden sie den typischen fall der
überschuldung heute beschreiben den
typischen fall gibt es eigentlich nicht
es sind praktisch alle
bevölkerungsschichten betroffen man
nimmt ihr allgemein an dass nur jene mit
niedrigem einkommen betreibungen haben
aber das trifft nicht zu wir stellen in
unserem alltag fest dass viele menschen
die finanziell gut da zu stehen scheinen
durch eben ein ereignis in ihrem leben
mit betreibungen konfrontiert werden
das ist neu relativ neu
vor wenigen jahren waren es noch
mehrheitlich menschen mit geringem
einkommen oder randständige
heute steht ganz klar der mittelstand
unter dem druck von höheren schulden
verbucht und google eine puk wie ging
das bei ihnen los du bist nun sieht
ihnen ganz einfach ich wurde entlassen
und zwar ziemlich ungerechtfertigt
ein erster harter schlag ins gesicht
jetzt nachdem ich nicht gefasst war
ich lande in der arbeitslosigkeit und
ein paar monate später verlässt mich
meine frau trennung
das war der anfang meines freien falls
damals war ich nach oben aber dann bin
ich tief gefallen
was war damals ihre position
ich war in leitender stellung tätig
verantwortlicher der
kommunikationsabteilung einer
fachhochschule
also ein guter sozialer status ein gutes
einkommen von knapp unter 10.000 viele
freunde also einen ganz in
anführungszeichen normales leben von dem
man im studium träumt wie noch nie
rita 54 91 1984 franken 50 schulden bei
mir begann es mit 5000 franken einen
konsumkredit den ich ganz einfach bekam
aber dann wurde es kompliziert weil es
so einfach war
jedes mal wenn ich 3000 bezahlte bot man
mir einen neuen kredit an und ich bis an
die schrieben mir ich sei eine gute
kundin usw
und dieses denken übernahm ich sie
hatten damals ein gutes einkommen ja ich
war damals für 22 mitarbeiter
verantwortlich und machte einen
ansehnlichen umsatz in einem großen
geschäft
ich hatte keine betreibungen und bekam
das geld von den banken geliehen und
eines schönen tages fällt alles in sich
zusammen und plötzlich ist alles weg
nach 21 jahren im betrieb war da auf
einmal jemand dem ich nicht passte und
er mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
ich schrieb meinem arbeitgeber dass ich
mit dieser person nicht arbeiten wolle
und verlor meine stille und statt 6000
franken verdiente ich als einfache
verkäuferin nur noch 4200 dann wurden
meine situation bewusst du hast
jahrelang über seinen verhältnissen
gelebt meine liebe twitter blog
und jetzt stehst du da eine schallende
ohrfeige
eine ohrfeige zum preis von fast 92.000
franken
klingt nach enorm viel aber bei
jährlichen zinsen um die 15 prozent sind
die schulden von rita sacramento
vorwiegend konsumkredite ganz einfach
sehr rasant angestiegen
bei solchen zinssätzen verdoppeln sich
schulden alle fünf jahre wenn man sie
nicht abbezahlt das ganze lief etwa zehn
jahre lang so ich fand keinen ausweg
ich hatte immer einen bankkredit weil es
nur das gab
ich hatte diverse kreditkarten
was haben sie mit allem geld gemacht ich
habe mir einen eidgenössischen
fachausweis geleistet mich weiterbilden
lassen
meine kinder waren in der skischule und
lernten schöne orte in der schweiz
kennen
zermatt und so wir haben schöne ferien
gemacht das war ich wieder die ihren
kindern dies und das bietet heute sage
ich mir mein gott was für eine
verantwortungslosigkeit meinerseits aber
auch seitens der banken
beide seiten handelten komplett
verantwortungslos ich profitierte vom
schnellen geld und die bank von meiner
naivität oder meiner lebensfreude
das muss man schon so sagen solche fälle
von überschuldung durch kleinkredite
kennt sebastian es hier zur genüge bei
ihm herrscht hochbetrieb
mercier arbeitet bei der
schuldenberatung schweiz dem
gemeinnützigen schweizer dachverband der
schuldenberatungsstellen jedes jahr wird
die kaufkraft kleiner das heißt die
löhne werden zwar gelegentlich angehoben
aber die krankenkassenprämien und die
mieten steigen stärker an wodurch eben
kaufkraft verloren geht
da wir in einer wachstums gesellschaft
leben muss der konsum trotzdem
stimuliert werden deshalb werden den
menschen kredite angeboten und so gerät
man leicht in einen teufelskreis sobald
das fass zum überlaufen gebracht wird
sobald das einkommen auch nur in
geringem maße sinkt oder die
lebenskosten steigen
selbst ein positives ereignis wie die
geburt eines kindes kann einen haushalt
in die überschuldung stürzen
das will man nicht wahrhaben man glaubt
lieber die leute seien selber schuld
bei uns herrschen auf diesem gebiet
etwas seltsame vorstellungen bezüglich
der persönlichen verantwortung
in den letzten zehn jahren sind die
krankenkassenprämien doppelt so schnell
und die mieten eineinhalb mal so schnell
angestiegen wie die löhne
in der region genfersee klafft die
schere noch weiter auseinander
pierre-yves gardiner hat sich gerade
wieder etwas aufgefangen und eine
vollzeitstelle in der
informatikausbildung gefunden dies nach
zwei jahren arbeitslosigkeit und einem
fünfjährigen leidensweg man hat mir
geraten mich ans sozialamt zu wenden was
ich auch tat
so ein kafkaeskes erlebnisse
ausgerechnet ich in einer solchen
situation in der man von oben herab
behandelt wird von leuten die keine
ahnung haben total von oben herab eine
pro- ge
was haben sie zur sozialhilfe gesagt ich
habe es abgelehnt
ein echtes finanzielles problem sind die
alimente ich wollte sie unbedingt
bezahlen das sind ja meine kinder die
ich liebe die kann ich nicht im stich
lassen mit krieg ich hatte das geld
nicht ich musste mich also mit
gelegenheitsjobs über die runden bringen
also teure alimente dazu eine relativ
teure wenn auch erschwingliche mieten
und schon ist kein geld mehr da wäre man
abgelenkt die neben diesen beiden großen
posten nichts mehr übrig bleibt was tust
du dann das heißt eine rechnung nicht
steuern die versicherung
psychologisch macht es sich völlig
fertig lasst das gefühl dein eigenes
nicht verloren zu haben weil alles vom
sozialen status und von der arbeit
eigentlich ist aber so sind wir
letztlich nicht wir sind auch menschen
und wenn der mensch total am boden ist
kommt er mit der realität nicht mehr
klar
einer der seltenen lichtblicke im leben
von pierre yves kardinal ist dieser
waadtländer bauernhof dort mietete er
vier jahre lang eine wohnung bei einer
bäuerin bescheidene miete kostenloses
gemüse ich hatte erst keine ahnung dass
du kein geld hat ist natürlich war mir
mit der zeit schon klar dass es
schwierig war mit all diesen alimenten
von denen du erzählt hast da bleibt
einem ja wirklich nicht viel übrig ich
habe auch nicht gerne darüber gesprochen
man schämt sich natürlich sharif
gardiner schämte sich aber nicht nur
schnell hatte er auch panische angst
davor den briefkasten zu öffnen
die post türmt sich schnell auf es
klingt lächerlich aber ich kam damit
einfach nicht zurecht
es ist ein schreckliches gefühl jeden
tag in diesem stapel vorbei zu gehen
oder die sind dann will nur eins ihn
verbrennen
man will ihn einfach nicht wahrhaben
habe ich sie die briefe geöffnet nein
nein ich nahm sie aus dem kasten weil
die vermieterin nichts mitbekommen
sollte aber drin habe ich alles auf
einen stapel gelegt und dann flüchtete
ich in die wälder um den stress
abzubauen publikum
es macht dich kaputt
es liegt an dir hast du überhaupt wie
sie die mir du trinkst oder nimmst
medikamente zum schlafen und gegen
depressionen und traurigkeit du
realisierst dass du nicht mehr in der
lage bist deine pflichten zu erfüllen
ich hatte ja nie die absicht meine
kredite nicht zurück zu bezahlen
ich konnte zahlen oder meinte es
zumindest das ist das problem
und als ich plötzlich nur noch 4200
franken verdiente konnte ich es nicht
mehr so eine puppe im nachhinein muss
ich sagen dass ich schon mit dem höheren
lohn über meinen verhältnissen gelebt
hatte man realisiert es nicht ich bekam
einen lohn bezahlte überall das minimum
setzte da und dort meine karten ein und
schon steckte ich mittendrin in der
spirale der berg wird immer größer bis
irgendwann alles platzt
das erste erwachen hatte ich mit einem
sehr lieben freund von mir der märkte in
welcher verfassung ich war immer geht er
stellte mir die frage was ist los agency
vollbracht die fassade zusammen
endlich konnte ich darüber sprechen
dieser freund schlug mir einen deal vor
ich komme es zu dir wir eröffnen
gemeinsam die post und schauen uns an
wie es steht
ich hatte angst davor habe ich sagte gut
wir machen das die mir hat es mir
ermöglicht die man für die hilfe aus der
sackgasse herauszukommen diplomatin
grässlich und so wurde ihnen das ausmaß
ihrer finanziellen misere bewusst
genau wir haben ausgerechnet wie hoch
meine schulden waren hat alle offenen
rechnungen verlustscheine betreibungen
pfändungen und so weiter in einer excel
tabelle aufgelistet das resultat war
erschreckend er sagte mir jetzt zeige
ich dir wie man aus einem solchen
schlamassel herauskommt genau das
brauche ich so einen großen bruder der
mich an der hand nimmt und aus diesem
saustall führt tut mir leid aber anders
kann man das nicht beschreiben
20 prozent unserer klienten haben seit
über zehn jahren schulden seit mehr als
zehn jahren sagen sie sich jeden monat
diese rechnung wirklich mal beiseite
dafür bezahle ich eine andere für die
ich schon gemahnt worden bin
sie haben also jeden monat stress mit
den zahlungen und einige leute kriegen
eine solche angst dass sie ihrem
briefkasten gar nicht mehr öffnen können
so wird das nackte überleben zur
hauptbeschäftigung man will nur noch den
stress los werden
dem bestreben diesen stress abzubauen
trifft man entscheidungen gegen die
eigenen interessen und solche
entscheidungen werden durch das
wirtschaftssystem begünstigt da
profilieren sich finanzinstitute mit
werbung wie finanzprobleme wir haben die
lösung für sich und riss ein 48 jähriger
afrikaner hat sich für eine solche
lösung entschieden 2014 sah er ein
inserat und nahm mit einem angesehenen
finanzsanierung unternehmen kontakt auf
der auftritt ist großartig es heißt ich
sei in der richtigen adresse
man werde sich um eine vollständige
entschuldung kümmern
letztlich atmet man einfach nur auf wo
man unterzeichnet ein paar dokumente
deren gläubigern geschickt werden und
dann läuft alles über sie
man bekommt von allem überhaupt nichts
mehr mit nach einem jahr stellt idris
fest dass nur die hälfte seines geldes
bei den gläubigern gelandet ist den rest
kassiert das institut als entschädigung
diese entschädigung war zwar vertraglich
vorgesehen aber idris hat sie
unterschätzt er beschließt den vertrag
aufzulösen
duschl april mit zwei tage später wird
mehr per einschreiben mitgeteilt ich
hätte mich dazu verpflichtet bis zu
meiner kompletten entschuldung zu
bleiben und es kostete mich mehr als
3000 franken wenn ich jetzt gehen würde
mir so geht das nicht
ich werde euch zeigen und antwortete und
wie soll es jetzt weitergehen
dort wir betreiben sie wenn sie nicht
zahlen
und ich sagte willkommen im club meiner
gläubiger die sache endet vor gericht
februar 2016 wird vertreten durch oliver
krischer von der caritas war hier der
beschluss der richterin die mir
vollumfänglich recht gegeben und die
klage abgewiesen hat die beklagte konnte
plausibel darlegen dass der vertrag eine
unrealistische sanierung zum ziel hatte
und offensichtlich unstatthaft und
unmoralisch war genau so sieht es das
gericht es hätte jahre dauern können
letztlich haben die monatlichen
zahlungen gerade mal etwas mehr als die
zinsen gedeckt er hätte 20 jahre lang
zahlen können ohne etwas an seiner
situation zu ändern
also keine rede von entschuldungen ist
sehr verlockend auf ein solches fantasie
angebot einzugehen und dann eine lösung
zu glauben obwohl das angebot keiner
näheren prüfung standhalten würde
wenn ich heute schon nicht meinen
gläubigern klar komme wie soll es denn
erst morgen klappen wenn ich noch ein
vermittler entschädigen musste nur in
den seltensten fällen die schulden
runter handelt manche tun es aber es ist
eher selten gibt es ein regelwerk für
solche sanierungsfirmen meines wissens
gibt es keine
in der schweiz herrscht für jedermann
die vertragsfreiheit gut es gibt das
obligationenrecht aber wenn jemand trotz
überschuldung monatlich einen vermittler
bezahlen möchte dem vorgaukelt ihn aus
der sackgasse zu führen dann ist das
rechtmäßig
der verleger die firma deren namen
erwähnt bleiben soll hat das urteil
nicht angefochten und will sich auch
nicht vor unserer kamera äußern
der geschäftsleiter teilt uns
schriftlich mit die fraglichen beträge
würden kein weiteres verfahren
rechtfertigen und es entspreche nicht
der firmenpolitik mit schwerem geschütz
gegen kunden vorzugehen ist ihnen diese
firma bekannt
na ja wir haben uns mit dieser firma
schon des öfteren herumgeschlagen
aber sie ist nicht die einzige solche
firmen gibt es in allen landesteilen
die auswahl ist echt groß und nimmt vor
allem weiter zu es sind unternehmen die
aufs geldverdienen aus sind manche gehen
dabei mehr oder weniger korrekt vor
andere überhaupt nicht wieso wohl
korrekt und leider muss ich sagen dass
es unter den unsauberen viel üblere gibt
als diese firma es gibt viel zu tun im
budget erstellen
den genauen betrag ihrer schulden
ermitteln
und wenn mal alles bezahlt zum glück ist
dieser privatwirtschaftliche weg nicht
die einzige möglichkeit in den letzten
zehn jahren haben sich verschiedene
gemeinnützige vereinigung auf die
entschuldung spezialisiert darunter vor
allem die caritas und das soundtrack
sozialproteste beide unter der aufsicht
des dachverbandes schuldenberatung
schweiz gemeinsam mit den sozialämtern
betreiben diese vereinigung in mehreren
westschweizer kantonen eine hotline die
krankenkassenprämie hat sie einfach
nicht mehr bezahlt wie muss man sich den
typischen anrufer auf diese hotline
vorstellen
wir haben vorwiegend leute die
eigentlich zu spät anrufen wenn sie
keinen ausweg mehr sehen völlig am ende
sind ihre rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen
können oder bereits gepfändet werden
oder die pfändungen laufen schon seit
jahren und plötzlich gibt es aus
irgendeinem grund ein problem dass sie
nicht mehr bewältigen können
elodie eine 27 jährige bäckerin
konditorin hatte lange gezögert sich
ihren schulden zu stellen
vier jahre lang hatte sie den kopf in
den sand gesteckt heute lebt sie mit
ihrem freund in der gegend von
villeneuve
sie bekam mehrere betreibungen und
vorladungen wurde auch mal eine pfändung
oder sony gingen jeweils die sicherungen
durch mich an wo ich nichts dafür konnte
ich sagte ihr nun beruhige dich mal aber
nicht einmal das brachte sie zum handeln
sie hatte alles am liebsten in die luft
gesprengt
es ist offensichtlich dass er das selbst
nie erlebt hat aber wenn du erst einmal
drin steckst dann ist es schwierig
wieder rauszukommen
hoffnungen ich habe mein geld verprasst
sondern immer das absolute minimum
ausgegeben ich bin mit 15 einhalb jahren
wegen familiärer probleme von zu hause
weg allein in eine einzimmerwohnung das
war 2009
und dann begannen die probleme ich war
auf mich alleine gestellt und wusste
nicht wie man mit den persönlichen
geschäften umgeht so ließ sich halt die
post im briefkasten liegen dekorierte
kabarett lilo die 27 36 tausend franken
schulden wie viele andere junge menschen
die zu früh auf sich alleine gestellt
sind musste elodie einen hohen preis für
ihre unabhängigkeit seien innerhalb von
nur drei jahren fällt sie tief und sieht
sich mit betreibungen konfrontiert und
dies nur wegen eines fehlers ihrer
krankenkasse einer koppel ich hatte eine
prämienverbilligung erhalten bekam aber
rechnungen über den vollen betrag circa
350 franken grundprämie wovon ich 40
franken übernehmen musste und sie haben
das nicht bezahlt ich habe nicht bezahlt
weil mir nicht klar war weshalb mir die
krankenkasse rechnungen über die volle
prämie und nicht nur über meinen anteil
schickt es ging um eine summe die ich
nicht zahlen konnte ich habe nicht
schnell genug reagiert weil ich dachte
ich kenne die 40 franken vielleicht
später zahlen aber letztlich wurde die
gesamte summe über zwei jahre fällig
weil die krankenkasse die
subventionsgelder zurück gesandt hatte
da mein anteil nicht bezahlt worden
allein für die krankenkasse beläuft sich
der geschuldete betrag auf 18.000
franken einschließlich arztkosten deren
erstattung die kasse verweigert ihnen
damals klar was passiert ja und nein es
war mir klar dass sich da probleme
anhäuften
aber ich hatte das geld nicht um
betreibungen von mehr als 2000 bis 3000
franken zu begleichen
ich verdiente 800 franken mit meiner
wohnung konnte ich mir kaum vorstellen
das geld je zurück bezahlen zu können
bis eines tages morgens um sechs die
polizei bei mir klingelt um mich aufs
betreibungsamt zu bringen
da wurde mir klar dass ich große
probleme hatte elodie hat das pech dass
krankenkassen praktisch nie einen
prämien erlass akzeptieren
sie wird also den gesamten geschuldeten
betrag bezahlen müssen als mein erster
lohn auf dem konto einging wurde er
gleich gepfändet ich konnte nicht mal
die aktuellen rechnungen damit bezahlen
gleich auf ihrem konto gepfändet das
betreibungsamt hatte sich per
richterlichen beschluss zugriff auf mein
bankkonto verschafft ein schreckliches
gefühl das eigene bankkonto nicht mehr
benutzen zu können
in meiner not rief ich sofort die
caritas an wir konnten aushandeln dass
man mir monatlich etwas mehr lässt und
sich selbst auf die gläubiger zu gehen
so begann ich alles zurückzuzahlen
und wie viel haben sie töten können
27.000 in 18 monaten ist das möglich mit
einem lohn von 4.000 mich sehr hart man
verzichtet auf vieles und kann nicht
wirklich über sein geld verfügen kann
meinen eltern habe ich nichts erzählt
weil es mir peinlich war
ich habe alles für mich behalten ich
habe mich zurückgezogen
viele kontakte verloren
verkrochen und das leben an mir
vorbeiziehen eine form der
selbstverleugnung aber durchaus mit
einem lichtblick für mich ist saß ihr
das wichtigste der betreibungs auszug
ich bin sehr stolz dass er heute keinen
einzigen eintrag mehr aufweist
klima aus 21 10000 franken schulden
guten tag corelli traxel csp la chaux de
fonds
es geht um eine meiner klientinnen frau
claudia offenbar sind ihre
krankenkassenprämien von ihrer mutter
nicht bezahlt worden
sie ging als ob er für ein jahr in die
usa und stellte nach ihrer rückkehr fest
dass die prämien nicht bezahlt waren
wir möchten der verschuldung ein ende
setzen und schauen wie wir mit den
ausstehenden zahlungen umgehen wir
könnten eventuell bezüglich der
verwaltungskosten eine einigung finden
sie machen bis ende november keine
weitere betreiberin einverstanden
mein fall ist etwas speziell
ich habe bis 2014 studiert und ging dann
für ein jahr ins ausland
meine mutter sagte mir ich bezahle seine
krankenkassenprämien und alles nötige
bist du genügend geld verdienst weil sie
dann allerdings nicht hat kommt dazu
dass die mutter von clemmons eigene
verpflichtungen hat denen sie nicht
nachkommt drei jahre lang hält sie die
post ihrer tochter zurück
wegen der betreibungen kommt ihr
clemence letztlich auf die schliche ich
habe zufällig eine zahlungsaufforderung
über einen betrag von 150 franken
entdeckt aus dem ihr letztlich schulden
in höhe von fast zehntausend franken
entstanden sind
ich verstand die welt nicht mehr und war
hilflos und völlig perplex ich fragte
ganz direkt was soll das wie lange geht
das schon so man sagte mir sie sind
schon seit drei jahren bei uns
registriert in dieser situation
innerhalb von 24 stunden war alles ja
mir fehlen die worte
ich hatte keine lust mehr so weiter zu
machen ohne zu verstehen welche
konsequenzen es für mich haben kann
jetzt kümmere ich nicht selbst um alles
aber natürlich empfinde ich auch das
will ich gar nicht leugnen eine gewisse
wird eine große wut aber irgendwie ist
es zu anstrengend er ist immer wieder
übel zu nehmen
das hilft mir auch nicht weiter aber ich
erlaube mir und glaube das recht zu
haben wütend auf sie zu sein
begegnen sie solchen fällen häufig
leider haben immer mehr junge menschen
probleme mit der krankenkasse 18 oder 20
jährige
und wenn sie sich nicht sofort an uns
wenden kann es zu einer lohnpfändung
kommen das ist ziemlich
niederschmetternd
weil man sich schuldig fühlt gegenüber
den eltern und wenn der erste lohn
gleich gepfändet wird kann das zu einem
ganz schwierigen start ins arbeitsleben
für sie bekommen ihren ersten
lehrlingslohn 600 franken
stellen sie sich vor sie leben noch bei
ihren eltern
wie würden sie mit dem geld umgehen um
leidvolle erfahrungen wie jene von
clemmons oder elodie zu vermeiden wird
zunehmend auf prävention gesetzt dass
sozialprotesten bietet kurse zum umgang
mit geld an
die kurse sind vorwiegend für
gymnasiasten und lehrlinge gedacht hier
sind wir in einem institut für
berufliche wiedereingliederung die
reisespesen zahlen die eltern die
arztkosten auch die eltern die
schulgebühren ebenfalls aber ihnen fehlt
doch das geld nein wir sparen doch wieso
geben sie diese kurse weil es sonst
niemand tut
außerdem ist entschuldung mein
arbeitsgebiet ist wir müssen stärker
präventiv handeln damit letztlich
weniger menschen mit ihren schulden zu
uns kommen müssen doch trouvain april es
wird viel zu wenig aufklärung betrieben
man mag denken die leute verschulden
sich mal sie zu viel ausgeben
aber ich glaube dass es in der großen
mehrheit der fälle um mangelnde
information geht und die leute nicht mit
dem geld umgehen können wäre das nicht
aufgabe der schule
man lernt dass nirgends vor allem wenn
papa und mama nicht dafür sorgen haben
sie alle schon eine steuererklärung
ausgefüllt
das ist wirklich wichtig auch wenn man
nicht richtig weiß sie einfach mal
ausfüllen unterschreiben und einsenden
in der schweiz sind steuer ausstände der
größte posten der überschuldung gefolgt
von krankenkassenprämien und
konsumkrediten gemäss bundesamt für
statistik hat mehr als jeder zehnte
schweizer steuerschulden
es ist also kein zufall dass dieses
thema in den kursen systematisch
behandelt wird
und offensichtlich gibt es viel zu tun
haben sie die steuererklärung im griff
überhaupt nicht ich habe ja keine wahl
ich muss es tun was ist das problem
sie haben doch den ganzen stapel gesehen
die man bekommt da hat man keine lust
drauf
ich nehme mir einfach nicht die zeit
dafür
wie alt sind sie 25 sie haben noch nie
eine ausgefüllt doch einmal vor 23
jahren
[Musik]
wir sind auch selber schuld
man kann es lernen ziemlich umständlich
etwas auszufüllen um dann nichts zu
bezahlen
sinnlos finde ich ausfüllen wenn du
keine steuern zahlen muss keine
papierverschwendung das ist nicht
umweltfreundlich die leute vom steueramt
sind schnüffler und umweltverschmutzer
wenn sie sich weigern dann habe ich ein
problem
zugegeben administrativ ist alles
umständlicher geworden ob steuern
krankenkassen oder unterstützungs
anträge aber im gegensatz zur
vorherrschenden meinung sind die jungen
nach neuester statistik nicht stärker
verschuldet als ihre eltern
immer häufiger ist jedoch das system
selbst die ursache der probleme
telefonie problem er kam wegen einer
zahnarzt rechnung
er wusste nicht wie er sie bezahlen nach
einem blick auf sein budget war sofort
klar dass es zusammen mit den steuern
nicht klappen würde
er ist geschieden muss alimente zahlen
und kommt finanziell nicht über die
runden
und was macht er falsch ach ja nichts
das ist es ja er kann gar nichts dagegen
tun sagt er die steuern fällt er unter
das existenzminimum viele väter die
alimente zahlen können ihre steuern
nicht zahlen
das problem ist dass richter und anwälte
nicht an die steuern denken wenn sie
alimente berechnen
als der fahrer 51 3800 franken schulden
dieser türkischstämmige schweizer steht
vor einer unlösbaren aufgabe rein
rechnerisch kann er seinen
lebensunterhalt nicht bestreiten wenn er
seine steuern bezahlt und so hat er seit
drei jahren steuerschulden
obwohl er nie zahlungs ausstände hatte
seit er vor 30 jahren in die schweiz kam
und seit er als unverheiratet gilt hat
sich seine steuerrechnung verdoppelt ist
es hart für sie verschuldet zu sein ja
sehr hart ich kann es nicht akzeptieren
schulden dürfen nicht sein ich hatte den
gleichen lohn keinen rappen mehr oder
weniger mit einer fünfköpfigen familie
es ging uns gut wir waren weder reich
noch arme wir machten jedes jahr ferien
aber jetzt geht das nicht mehr
mein lohn ist durchschnittlich und mir
bleibt nur ein minimum zum leben
der rest verschwindet einfach so die
wussten sich am mittwoch mit einer
scheidung hatte ich nie gerechnet sie
schlug ein wie eine atombombe
ich verlor meine position als
familienvater wie mein leben bestand nur
aus arbeit und familie familie und
arbeit und sonst nichts zum glück bleibt
mir die arbeit
sie ist wie ein medikament für mich und
sie funktionieren trotzdem weiter nein
eigentlich nicht
aber ich muss jedes zweite wochenende
meine kinder übernehmen und dann
geteilte ferien obwohl ich alles budget
nur das minimum an geld für eine person
habe aber was bleibt mir anderes übrig
außerdem hat man zuvor in der familie
einfach alles unterdrückt da gab es
vieles was unterdrückt wurde
all das geht einem dauernd durch den
kopf
mustafa zengin ist jeden monat bemüht
aus seinen bescheidenen mitteln
wenigstens einen kleinen teil der
steuern zu tilgen
coralie traxel vom cs manager tel hat
letztes jahr versucht im gegenzug zu
seiner zahlungswilligkeit einen
steuernachlass zu erwirken
der antrag ist in letzter instanz
gutgeheissen worden
es heißt hier angesichts der tatsache
dass es für den antragsteller bedingt
durch umstände auf die er keinen
einfluss hat besonders schwerwiegende
konsequenzen hätte wenn er seiner
steuern vollständig bezahlen würde also
an erkennt sogar der regierungsrats dass
er unter dem existenzminimum liegt aber
hat er keine andere möglichkeit als
jedes jahr beim regierungsrat einen
antrag auf steuererlass zu stellen
fühlen sie sich nicht manchmal den fluss
komplett aber sicher und ich finde es
völlig ungerecht es ist logisch dass er
sich verschuldet wenn er für 2015 keinen
steuererlass bekommt und ich ihn
überhaupt nicht helfen kann
dabei verhält er sich doch absolut
korrekt archiv du aber das system ist
einfach nicht für getrennt lebende oder
geschiedene gemacht solche parini vox
das problem der steuern und des
existenzminimums zeigt sich nicht nur
bei der berechnung von alimenten sondern
auch im fall von betreibungen die
steuern sind in den mitteln die man den
betriebenen lässt nicht inbegriffen
ist das nicht reine heuchelei betriebene
verschulden sich weiter und werden bei
ihnen zum dauergast vermuten diese frage
stellt sich vor allem auf politischer
ebene tatsächlich immer wieder aber
bisher das bundesgericht stets bestätigt
dass die steuern nicht zu den
lebenswichtigen zahlungsverpflichtungen
gehörend erweitern
auf bundesebene gibt es verschiedene
bemühungen das gesetz abzuändern
aber mit einer immer stärkeren rechten
im parlament verpuffen die vorstöße der
progressiven parlamentarier schnell dies
zum großem missfallen der
schuldenberatung schweiz die nun über
die kantone bewegung in die sache
bringen will
wenn sie glauben dass über kantonales
recht etwas zu machen sein könnte dann
wäre ich interessiert
wir bemühen uns um unterstützung durch
die kantone schliesslich haben sie den
schaden
sie tragen die steuerausfälle die
möglicherweise auch zu
sozialhilfeleistungen führen und sie
müssen politisch etwas gegen die
überschuldung unternehmen also sind sie
auf bundesebene ein wichtiger akteur
wenn es darum geht die gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern
bei pierre yves maillard dem waadtländer
staatsrat rennt er offene türen
man zwingt jemanden über lohnpfändungen
zur entschuldung und macht ihn
gleichzeitig zum steuerschuld das ist
absurd
ich kann die blockade in national- und
ständerat in dieser frage überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen
ich bin dafür dass die steuern in der
berechnung des existenzminimums
berücksichtigt werden die steuern müssen
teil des minimums an mitteln sein dass
man den betroffenen lässt weil sonst
eben eine lohnpfändung dazu führt dass
sie sich wegen der steuern erneut
verschulden müssen
ein teufelskreis für mich ist das ganze
nicht nachvollziehen
die kantone ergreifend schon mal ihre
eigenen maßnahmen immer mehr von ihnen
führen entschuldungsfonds ein um den
betroffenen unter die arme greifen zu
können
im kanton waadt hat pierre yves maillard
sieben jahre lang für einen solchen
fonds gekämpft seit 2015 gibt es ihn nun
pierre yves gardiner steht ganz am
anfang seines weges begleitet wird er
durch die uni wien die finanz sanierungs
stelle des sozialamtes losern ihre
schulden belaufen sich auf 36.400 30
franken
das heißt sie müssen drei jahre lang
monatlich 474 franken zurückzahlen
ja dass ich auch so dazu kommen zwei
drittel ihres 13 monatslohns immer ende
des jahres auch über drei jahre
die zwei drittel machen 4186 franken aus
marl 3 also 12.500 58 franken 5 das tut
weh aber das betreibungsamt die würden
ihnen alles nehmen
der fonds funktioniert nach einem
einfachen prinzip der kanton entschädigt
die gläubiger direkt und versucht dabei
einen schuldennachlass auszuhandeln
so erhalten die gläubiger ihr geld
fristgerecht während sie sonst eventuell
jahre darauf warten müssten
der schuldner verpflichtet sich
seinerseits dem vor das geld innerhalb
von drei jahren in monatlichen raten
zurück zu bezahlen
es ist jetzt keine wendung mehr aber
etwas ähnliches die maschinen berechnet
ein existenzminimum machen aber sie ist
viel humaner gibt sie zeigt mitgefühl
ich schätze ihre arbeit es ist
grundsätzlich dasselbe ein
existenzminimum aber doch ein etwas
größeres budget
man hat reserven und ist durch die
unerfreulichen vom einkommen bleibt
einem eine verfügbare summe mit der man
schulden tilgen kann das verfahren
dauert maximal drei jahre
august endet ganz schön lange aber man
sieht wenigstens endlich mal licht am
ende des tunnels das ist großartig
gardiner ist 50 jahre alt und schweizer
ja drei kinder
aber aufgepasst noch ist die sache für
ihn nicht erledigt das dossier gardiner
muss erstmal durch den vorstand
abgesegnet werden und das ist nur die
erste etappe das darlehen für helga
diener muss erst durch den fonds
gutgeheissen werden dann folgen die
verhandlungen mit den gläubigern
wir bitten sie um einen nachlass von 40
prozent und müssen schauen ob sie
einverstanden sind
wir haben gute argumente
herr kardinal hat keine neuen schulden
gemacht und ist seinen verpflichtungen
bisher nachgekommen
aber alles hängt von den gläubigern
med der nachteil eines solchen fonds ist
das letztlich nur wenige davon
profitieren
die kriterien sind streng man muss mit
seinem lohn das darlehen in 36 monaten
tilgen können in der realität erfüllt
nicht mal jeder zehnte überschuldete
diese kriterien in allen anderen fällen
können oft nur neue schulden verhindert
oder bestenfalls eine teil entschuldung
ins auge gefasst werden wir stehen am
anfang einer staatlichen
entschuldungspolitik keine einfache
sache
denn wenn der staat bei überschuldung
systematisch zu hilfe eilt dann könnte
das die überschuldung fördern weil die
menschen denken das risiko sei nicht so
groß und der staat werde ja schon
einspringen
das könnte sich sowohl für die
verschuldeten als auch auf die
entschuldungsfonds negativ auswirken
wenn die darlehensgeber nie mit konkurs
und zahlungsunfähigkeit konfrontiert
werden
dann werden sie ohne ende weitere
darlehens produkte entwickeln die
politik deswegen ist staatliches
eingreifen nicht einfach es muss moderat
bleiben es muss ein kleines bisschen
gezielt und dennoch allgemein gültig
sein
rita sacramento hat pech sie wird durch
den fonds nicht unterstützt weil einer
ihrer gläubiger ein einziger einen
schuldennachlass gewähren wollte damit
ist das projekt gescheitert
die uni wien empfiehlt ihr demzufolge
den privatkonkurs das wort an sich
bedeutet schon dass dir alles entzogen
wird und du nichts mehr hasst du tauchst
nichts das muss man erst mal verkraften
er psychisch als finanziell blutdruck
technic der begriff privatkonkurs ist
eine psychische belastung
das gericht erklärte sich für unfähig
mit einem geld umzugehen
das ist schon sehr hart
ein privatkonkurs in der schweiz ist
nicht vergleichbar mit einem konkurs in
den usa dort bekommt man eine zweite
chance und beginnt wieder von vorn
in der schweiz wird jedoch nichts
gestrichen
man kriegt nur einen zahlungsaufschub
bis man finanziell wieder besser dasteht
und das ist kein zufall das ist wohl
eine frage der schweizer mentalität bei
uns ist es gesetztes tradition leute zu
brandmarken die betrieben werden und
sich der verschuldung schuldig gemacht
habe im deutschen begriff schulden
steckt ja auch das wort schuld
mit unterstützung der uni wien kann rita
wenigstens mit allen gläubigern
verhandeln
ein eindrücklicher fall fast schon
beispielhaft für die una für die damit
in ihrer jüngsten kampagne wirbt ritas
gläubiger haben hier nachlass gewährt
bis zu 60 prozent
ein kampf den sie nicht nur gegen die
gläubiger sondern auch gegen sich selbst
geführt hat
so kann ich dampf ablassen wenn ich da
drauf heute denke ich an den ganzen
leidensweg und sag mir unglaublich ich
hab's geschafft
jetzt sind es noch 5000 350 franken und
am 31 dezember sind meine schulden auf
null
aber ich habe sehr sehr viel glück im
unglück gehabt als überschuldete bin ich
noch gut bedient
andere müssen eine wohnung bezahlen und
haben kinder
meine kinder waren schon ausgezogen und
für die wohnung haben ein freund auf
kassetten sterbe ich nicht gleich vor
hunger außerdem verdient rita seit fünf
jahren wieder fast so viel wie früher
sie ist heute geschäftsleiterin eines
caritas lebensmittelladens die stelle
ist wie für sie gemacht sie profitiert
dort ironie des schicksals von ihrer
erfahrung mit der überschuldung
fühlen sie sich schuldig so viel
ausgegeben zu haben
ich habe mich ziemlich gut unter
kontrolle
ich habe für meine beziehung damit
gefährdet und hätte meine stelle
verlieren können
nein kein schuldgefühl kein bedauern
aber eines ist sicher nie wieder
ich muss der 54 werden um zu erkennen
nur zugreifen wenn du geld hast aber von
schuld wollen wir nicht sprechen
ich habe rieter hat sich vergeben wie
die meisten anderen personen in diesem
film auch aber alle haben ihre
überschuldung als erniedrigen der
krankheit empfunden jeder für sich ganz
im stillen selbst elia der sohn von
pierre yves hat nichts gemacht
es war mir klar dass das leben keinen
spaß machte finanziell gesehen aber ich
hätte nie gedacht dass alles so den bach
runter gegangen war war immer der alte
immer derselbe nun ist das stolz weil er
es geschafft hat wieder aus der ganzen
scheiß herauszukommen
alle achtung
ich wollte mich unbedingt der
öffentlichkeit stellen weil diese
geschichte meine geschichte anderen
verzweifelten menschen als beispiel
dienen soll
ja ich wollte nur noch verschwinden aber
jenen die heute im schlamassel stecken
und keinen ausweg sehen will ich sagen
es gibt immer einen ausweg
[Musik]